ein forschungsteam hat direkt in unserer
nachbarschaft einen erdähnlichen
planeten entdeckt der tatsächlich
außerirdischen bei marken könnte er löst
damit die planeten im treff ist system
als nächste exoplaneten mit der chance
auf leben ab und ernährt sich und sogar
und wird bald näher als proxima centauri
sein wie es die lager auf ross 128 b
jetzt ein klick zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
als sich diese meldung entdeckt habe da
machte es bei mir klingen da war doch
was
am 12 mai diesen jahres wurden sehr
seltsame signale auf der erde empfangen
sie stammten vom zwerg sterne ross 128
das radioteleskop in treptow rico
empfing signale die zitat aus breitband
pulsen die nicht polarisiert waren und
sich quasi periodisch wiederholten
bestanden so abel mendes vom arecibo
radioteleskop aber was ist das für ein
signal sofort sprechen alle über aliens
und außerirdische signale doch auch wenn
das selbst den wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern sofort durch den kopf
schießt zuerst gibt es zahlreiche andere
möglichkeiten das wären zb flairs also
strahlungs ausbrüche des sterns
allerdings während die frequenzen viel
niedriger und die steuerung der signale
pass nicht möglichkeit zwei eine falsche
zuordnung der signale aber es gibt keine
objekte in richtung von ross 128 also
auch nichts für impulse von satelliten
allerdings geben die nicht solche
signale ab also auch busse und ja also
doch signale von außerirdischen
zitat wir haben hier ein mysterium jede
der drei erklärung ist im moment so gut
oder schlecht wie jede andere
das sagt mendes aber so mendes das heißt
noch lange nicht dass es ein alien
signal sein muss und auch selbst
schostag vom seti projekt das sind die
die nach außerirdischen signalen suchen
hält erst mal den ball flach keine
bestätigung es gibt noch zahlreiche
andere möglichkeiten und bis heute wurde
keine wirkliche erklärung gefunden so
wird er eine störung durch satelliten
vermutet aber eigentlich passt das eben
auch nicht und jetzt ist etwas passiert
dass diese entdeckung in eine vollkommen
anderen licht erscheinen lässt jetzt
werkstatt 128 wird von einem
erdähnlichen planeten genau in der zone
umkreis der habitablen wir kennen sie in
der leben möglich ist und er ist uns
relativ nahe 11 lichtjahre ist das
system mit dem exoplaneten ross 128 b
entfernt und auch aus 128 b umkreist
einen roten zwerg der für seine
strahlungs ausbrüche bekannt ist und
leben auf proxima centauri b
wahrscheinlich unmöglich macht das ist
mit vier lichtjahren entfernung der
nächste exoplaneten zurzeit aber ross
128 ist
ein ruhiger roter zwerg der leben in
seinem orbit ermöglichen würde jetzt
rückt der exoplaneten den fokus der
forschungsteams weltweit die entfernung
zum roten zwerg lässt temperaturen von
minus 60 plus 20 grad vermuten und die
strahlung ist dort noch 138 mal so hoch
wie hier auf der erde
obwohl der planet 20 mal mehr um seinen
stern kreist der roten zwerg ist nämlich
deutlich kälter als die sonne
was damit trotz der nähe leben auf ross
128 b ermöglichen würde er ist ein
sanfter roter zwergs 128 b braucht
übrigens nur rund zehn tage um seinen
stern zu kreisen
falls es dort jahreszeiten gebe wir
haben sie gerade mal zweieinhalb tage
lang naja wetter wird und wohl etwas
anders sein als hier auf der erde aber
jetzt kommt noch ein hammer horst 128
ist auf dem weg zu uns in für
astronomische zeiträume extrem kurzer
zeit wird ja schon unser nächster
nachbar sein
in knapp 80.000 jahren ist es soweit
jetzt heißt es warten aber nicht 80.000
jahre sondern auch anderthalb jahre dann
wird nämlich das james webb
weltraumteleskop ins all geflogen und
mit diesem revolutionären teleskop
können biomarker gefunden werden also
anzeichen für leben wenn es vielleicht
auch schon früher neues zu dieser
entdeckung gibt und vielleicht auch zu
den seltsamen signalen von dort dann
erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier drückt
mehr dazu hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
genau auf die glocke denn nur dann
werdet ihr über neue videos informiert
hier geht es weiter mit dem video
signale von außerirdischen empfangen
draufklicken wenn er mehr über die
seltsame signale von ross 128 erfahren
wollt ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran